[Music]
great okay cool thanks being here why
should we be traveling to space gosh
that's the big question
because it's there we can and we learn
so much by doing it okay so we start
with right there it's obvious we can we
can currently and and we'll learn so
much by doing it so that what we learn
we um
I mean space it's one of those things
it's it is the the next frontier Star
Trek se the final frontier but actually
there could be others we never know and
I grew up on science fiction and to me
it was the very logical thing to do but
then you grow up and you realize that
actually there are a lot of other
influences on space exploration there's
the money and the politics and you have
dance the big question of why we in the
UK pay into the European Space Agency
which means that we get to join other
countries doing really big projects and
so we get to be a part of exploring the
solar system but also doing climate
change missions weather forecasting and
the fundamentals of how we live now are
based on space if well the satellites
turned off we would live very different
lives and we also can explore and do
some of the big grand projects that you
can't do on your own and from those
grand projects we learn things that that
benefit us directly and indirectly so
space is really important okay so you
touched on it but where is space travel
at currently how to the next 10 15 20
years look what the big projects on the
horizon for the European Space Agency or
elsewhere so today we have people in
orbit on the International Space Station
and in fact there has been a constant
human and presence in space since the
year 2000 so nearly 20 years there have
been people over our heads and that's
often not really talked about but it's
quite an achievement we have the means
to get people there and back and that's
as far as we're going at the minute
there is a big grand plan to build a
space station in orbit around the moon
I've got the deep-space gateway so that
we can send people further away and then
from there get down to the surface of
the Moon very easily and learn about
living on another planet by living on
the moon and there is a plan of how to
do that but actually Donald Trump has
accelerated things because he has said
he wants people to be on the moon by
2024 and that's soon
so we we could be back on the moon but
with a longer more constant presence
there and and to do it it is an
international effort so the US will take
a big lead but actually they need
international help to do that what do we
stand to gain here from having people on
the moon they there are resources on the
moon that we don't have on earth and so
some of it could be mining things like
helium-3 some of it is is a political
statement that we can do it some of it
is that actually just progressing human
technology learning how to live in that
very extreme hostile environment and the
lessons that we learn and the
technologies that we develop filter
through into other parts of life there's
two examples I love I mean people talk
about the spin-offs from the space
program and you always hear an velcro
and Teflon neither of which were
actually invented by the space program
they were used extensively and
popularized but actually already existed
but there are some things that were
Invisalign braces that technology
actually came from the space program but
a more importantly suit biomedical
monitoring has created a system that
monitors infants for sudden death
syndrome and helps prevent it and
there's a planetary radar that is now
being used to detect landmines in a way
that wasn't possible before and so it's
those advances that if we can harness
and use on earth will really benefit us
the counter-argument is that the money
that goes these are these are side's
products you know and that the money
that goes into space could achieve that
and Exce
times more if it were focused not on
space but on those those sorts of areas
that we would you argument be there
well I mean they would we wouldn't be
making these breakthroughs if it weren't
for space travel services yes so my
argument would be the amount of money as
well that we put into space is not
nearly as much as everybody thinks the
European Space Agency have done some
analysis and they equated it to a cup of
coffee from everybody across Europe but
when you compare it to those budgets
that we're putting into health and
education it's really very small and so
the the benefit you'd get by saying no
more space let's only focus on this it's
not as big as you would like it to be so
so we we should explore space because as
you say it makes you look outside your
normal area of research we wouldn't have
invented these things if we had just
funneled the money into health because
they'd have been looking at something
else but we can take the benefits that
we've got from these technologies and
use them for really important purposes
what does the growth of private
enterprises private companies in space
sector and space travel offer that
wasn't being achieved by national or
international organisations the rise of
the commercial space companies is really
exciting I think we've got the big name
so Blue Origin founded by Jeff Bezos of
Amazon SpaceX Elon Musk
SpaceX it's an interesting case because
actually a lot of their funding is not
commercial it comes from NASA they're
part of the government's commercial
program to build a vehicle to get two
people to the International Space
Station but the way that they're doing
it is a very commercial method without
lots of the oversight and the sort of
government checks that the traditional
NASA contracts have but what they're
actually trying to do it is space
tourism and and that will be something
really different and that will be one of
the promises of science fiction so you
can buy a ticket at the minutes about
two without $200,000 on virgin and and
you'll have seven minutes weightlessness
and it's not very long but it's the
first step so I'll take you on a
suborbital hop but the advantage of that
would be we could get to space hotels
and then the next step could be maybe
we'll go to Australia in an
our rather than in 24 so it'll make the
world a bit smaller and it will take us
to places people don't travel to yet I
mean the benefit of space hotels is that
that people will get a view of the whole
planet with no borders and an every
astronaut who's come home has said that
that's changed how they think of the
world so imagine if we could get
politicians up and warring nations and
say look that's your little piece and
that's everything else and outfits that
could be interesting if a private
company is successful in colonizing
another planet would its board former
government I don't think it's been
planned for yet I don't think we have
the rules and regulations for that the
book the Martian and the movie sort of
tried to answer it a little bit with
well they had some interesting things on
space piracy the at the minute the only
way you can get there is with
governments and there are governments or
regulations on how you should act when
you're there but no would they own it I
mean until somebody else came along and
said they couldn't they I guess there'd
be the only people with access to any
minerals or any rights
so do you predict conflict between
government regulations and companies
over colonization we've seen early signs
of conflict in that all the countries
have signed up to rules on planetary
protection when it comes to Mars because
the Mars rover that we're going to send
next year it's going to look for signs
of life and so you in order to do that
you can't take any life with you and
that's governed by an international
treaty but somebody asked Elon Musk if
he was going to adhere to the planetary
protection rules and he said no he
didn't really believe in it and once you
send people you'll have too much
contamination anyway the u.s. is a
signature so actually it's the US
government's responsibility for because
he's a US owned company to sort of
monitor that and make the decision
really as to whether they're going to
stick to the treaty and but when we
start sending lots of people I mean
things will definitely have to change
and and maybe they should but we just
means we have to do
science bit a lot faster a lot sooner
because you might say what's more
important sort of digging around for
some microbes or sending people um
politically domestically and
increasingly in different countries
there's the feeling that travel along
with many other industries is a
significant contributor contributor to
climate change global warming what do
you make of the argument that we need
more greater thumb Burgh's and fewer you
know masks it's not really my area I
think that space itself is a huge
enabler for monitoring climate change
and tracking there have internationally
they've created the climate variables
that's 50 different criteria that you
have to measure to track the climate and
a significant proportion of those can
only be measured from space and many of
them you only get that global view from
space so if you want to see if people
are actually doing what they say they're
doing reducing emissions and cutting
down you need the satellites and so to
get the satellites you have to have the
rockets there is a push to make Rockets
greener the very large rockets are
actually fuelled by liquid oxygen and
liquid hydrogen and it turns into water
so you know some parts of the industry
are already very green satellites run on
solar power and so it sort of you could
say they were new able and yes and every
other industry we need to make sure that
that we also do our bit to to be as
climate conscious as possible because
it's it's critical but space is the one
area where we really need to make the
advances because that's how we're going
to to track everything and make sure
that our planet I mean it's how we know
we have a problem and it's how we know
will it solved it yeah and I guess what
stuff is there it's informative it's
helping and it's not contributing in any
way it's just getting it there yeah
that's there that's the thing to crack
and even that it isn't that bad we were
proportionally the effect of a rocket
compared to all of the global air travel
is tiny so there are many other problems
that we should fix to actually solve the
issue and believe in so we are working
on it okay so it's it's the moon by 2024
which will definitely happen we may be
more
when will we colonize Mars when well
when will humans reach Mars when will
human Street or Elon Musk who said he
wants to die on Mars but not on impact
and so he's got the rest of his lifetime
to one another sort of 30 40 years maybe
there is a plan to just go on to Mars
after the moons or the International
because of global and the global
Committee on exploration and they would
like to get people to Mars it's the next
place to send people to but we have to
learn other of the lessons on how to do
that on the moon and the inner
sustainable way sort of the Apollo
mission was a big enormous program but
it was very much driven by the aim is to
land on the moon and it and it took a
lot of money resources because it was a
race and so they had to do it fast
whereas now we're looking at how do we
do it sustainably and to take benefit of
everything when we get there and then go
on to Mars so so as to when we're
approaching 2020 so in the 2030s 2040s
and where more commercial space travel
will be Wow I would say affordable but
maybe more affordable well the model for
space travel is very interesting they're
taking people who are huge enthusiasm
and can afford it and then getting them
to fund all the initial stages so that
the price can then come down a little
bit like air travel was in the early
days you know you you had to you had to
be wealthy to be able to afford it um
Virgin Galactic have have said next year
they've said next year for several years
but but there next year is getting
closer and closer and so they are nearly
there so I that's always very hard to
predict especially because it's sort of
human safety is on the line
so nobody wants to rush anything because
it has to be safe and that is the first
option it's not you don't have to be
first you have to be careful but if they
do get up next year with the sort of the
early flights and the the sort of
founder members and the the initial
pioneers who then I was 2020 and and it
successful and carries on there may be
by the end of the decade it'll be an
affordable activity for lots of us and
would you you go yes I would definitely
go fulfilling the science-fiction
childhood aspiration absolutely I mean I
was a teenager when Star Trek The Next
Generation came out and I was gonna be
on a starship one day it's gonna take a
while I think but you never know for
more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV
you